do you know about the excellence in
theatre education award carnegie mellon
and our wonderful partners the Broadway
League and the American Theatre Wing are
teaming up to recognize teachers who
promote the Arts
I applaud my teacher Catherine Whitaker
Karen Stratton and Andrew Steinberg John
Prine mackaninee of ms 51 in Brooklyn
New York because he taught me to always
take risks and the importance of
imagination in creating anything she
really taught me how much hard work and
dedication needs to go into theatre in
order to make it great who inspires you
tell us a story judges are going to be
looking for videos that show why your
teacher is inspiring and your videos
don't even have to be professional as
long as they come from the heart to tell
your story all you need is a smart phone
go to Tony Awards calm / Education Award
to find more details you have until
februari 29 so do it the winner will be
featured at the 2016 Tony Award which
will be on jun 12 so don't miss it once
you've sent in your submission be sure
to use the hashtag applaud my teacher to
spread the word about just how great
your teacher is I mean I had tons of
great role models in high school and I'm
sure all of you guys did too so be sure
to submit your story because all
educators deserve recognition thank a
teacher who inspired you